this isn't the story i expected to tell
here and i want to be clear at the very
start
grignard island on the west coast of
scotland is not a tourist destination
there's not much to see and what there
is you can see it from the mainland
but if you really do want to get closer
there is a way and these days the
government won't even try and stop you
while i think scottish right to rome law
would allow us to land this boat and
have a walk around
the owners of the island asked that i
don't and that's fair enough one of the
reasons i want to respect that request
is because
there is quite a history of englishmen
coming up to the scottish islands and
acting like we own the place grignard
island here in world war
ii this is where britain tested its
biological weapons
it was contaminated for decades and
landing was dangerous and illegal
it has another unofficial name anthrax
island
and traditionally at this point
television crews go into the history of
the place and there'd be
a lot of pontificating about whether
britain would ever have actually used
lethal anthrax bacteria as a weapon
the government has always maintained
that the experiments on grignard island
sheep here
were just for defence to have data in
case we were attacked or as an early
form of mutually assured destruction
all the records i found back that up but
who knows what was said quietly in
private britain did draw up theoretical
attack plans that seems abhorrent now
but
in times of war the laws fall silent
this video isn't about that i'm telling
you that story
so i can tell you something else that i
found while researching
because it's often difficult to find
truth about history like this so
before traveling up here i went to look
at original documents in the national
archives
it's really amazing to me that
researchers can just
ask for those all the details are there
how much anthrax the scientists use in
each test how many sheep were killed and
how
the dimensions of the clouds of anthrax
given off and the scientists comments
about
just how effective it was but that's
been well told in books and articles in
all sorts of ways
it's been badly told as well like in an
overdramatic ustv segment from 2001
where
the journalist wears a completely
unnecessary respirator and hazmat suit
and he didn't need those because in the
1980s
the island was decontaminated partly
because of pressure and petitions from
the public and
there was also more startling pressure
when an anonymous group calling
themselves
dark harvest commando dumped anthrax
contaminated soil
outside one of the english government
research labs the people responsible
were never tracked down
and while all that was going on modern
tourism had become a thing in 1982 the
government had to deal with a couple of
europeans on holiday who just
landed on the island in an inflatable
dinghy and had a walk around
unaware of the danger that was still
there there's a letter in the archives
from british embassy
and it's this wonderful bit of
diplomatic writing
and it's among those more modern
documents that i stumbled on a story
about grignard island that
i don't think has ever been told because
in context
it's a fairly minor detail but out of
all the stories about the island
this is the one that stood out to me so
it's 1986 the decontamination was
successful the government used tons and
tons of formaldehyde disinfectant which
killed a few other things apart from the
anthrax but the ecosystem was steadily
starting to recover from that
for the government it all seemed to be
going well the press coverage was
mostly positive they got a lot of
attention for doing a good thing for
finally cleaning up an old mess
and of course the public's interested in
the whole thing newly cleaned up
secret wartime anthrax contaminated
island
is the sort of thing that attracts
people's attention and it was being sold
for only 500 pounds
slight catch there it was being sold for
500 pounds back to the original owners
because the government correctly was
honoring the original contract from the
1940s
which specified that once the island was
safe again the folks who'd sold it to
the government
or those people's descendants they'd
have the option of buying it back
for the same price they sold it for 500
pounds it was worth
much much more than that but 500 pounds
was the price
and 500 pounds they'd pay what this did
not mean
was that there was a bargain basement
private scottish island on sale but the
trouble is that
the press can sometimes gloss over some
of those details
as the decontamination story went out in
newspapers and magazines and tv
broadcasts
several government departments found
themselves dealing with a rush of
letters and telephone calls from the
public
all asking if they could buy the island
for 500 pounds
it has come to my attention that the
island of grignard is for sale
i'm interested in making an offer to
purchase i realize that getting voice
actors to read the letters out does make
them a bit funny but i don't unlock the
people sending the letters they weren't
ignorant
they'd just been told by an apparently
reliable source
that there was a private scottish island
available for 500 pounds i'd ask about
that
i might even try and beat the offer the
price offered is 500 pounds
i am prepared to offer 501 pounds
immediately
one woman from glasgow wrote the fear of
anthrax pales into insignificance to me
as i have lived adjacent to a council
rubbish dump for nearly three years
and it wasn't just british people the
enquiries came from all over the world
germany ethiopia bahrain the uae new
zealand a couple of homesick scottish
immigrants to australia
i often long for the old country people
wrote to any department that they
thought might be relevant the scottish
office the ministry of defence
a man from australia wrote directly to
the prime minister offering a thousand
dollars
please forgive me for writing directly
to you mrs thatcher but i'm hoping you
will forward this tender to the correct
department
that letter arrived three months after
the first ones this took a long time to
clear up not all the incoming letters
are in the archives
probably not all the replies either
there are also a couple of grumpy memos
from civil servants
passing the buck to one another about
dealing with the letters and the phone
calls
i do wonder if any of those writers
thought their letter would someday end
up preserved
in a national archive this isn't ancient
history that's why i've blocked out
their personal details
and i love this story because it shows
that misinformation
is not a new thing misunderstandings are
not a new thing even now
if you google who owns grignard island
you'll find an article about how russian
oligarchs want to buy it
dated april the 1st 2018. april fool's
day is a curse and we should abandon it
and anyone who has ever been in the
public eye even briefly
knows that one wrong word can come back
to haunt you for years
it might not even be your word the press
might misquote you or take you out of
context and
somehow the world gets the impression
that uh
for example you're the person to call
about a surprisingly cheap scottish
island
that doesn't have anthrax anymore